le premier centre français de planning
familial dit aussi de maternité heureuse
s'est ouvert à grenoble en présence de
nombreux médecins et personnalités
françaises et internationales
cet établissement est destinée avant
tout à l'information des couples et
surtout des femmes
préoccupé pour des raisons de santé de
régulariser et non pas de limiter les
naissances a déclaré le professeur
pascal président de la section aux
nobles oise de ce mouvement sur les
panneaux affichés dans ce centre les
membres du groupement peuvent prendre
connaissance des moyens qui leur sont
offertes pour favoriser la santé des
mères le bien-être des enfants et
l'équilibré du couple les moyens du
centre de grenoble consiste en cours
donnés par des personnalités compétentes